we turn to our phone line right now
and our friend from NFL Network the NFL
media group will be part of the ESPN NFL
Network coverage of the draft this year
my buddy Daniel Jeremiah move the sticks
on Twitter for those who don't follow
him you need to how are you DJ I'm doing
great rich I've I just got to get used
to the fact that you know every time I
go in my office now I assume that I'm on
camera throw me for a loop man like I
just want to get something off the
printer here but I feel like I got to be
careful like The Truman Show no I mean
you're always on television you're
you're always on TV and that I'm the sky
does not lie DJ see as you know to take
we could see some red flags and you just
got to be careful you know what I'm
saying you just got to be very joe
borrows one correct that's not any doubt
right that's a that's a fact yeah
ripping off I feel like that I feel like
that is a certainty there that he's
going to be the first pick in the
Bengals so they'll get their guy so then
the draft begins I think it three if we
assume that the chase young goes it too
and then the fun begins right and then
third overall
are the Lions now I know mock drafts do
not include trades how likely what are
you hearing right now about maybe an
itchy trigger finger by the Dolphins or
the Chargers knocking on the lines door
and saying we need to hop up to three to
make sure we get the quarterback we want
what are you hearing on that front right
now anything you know I know the Lions
about witness said that he's received
phone calls which every team's going to
make those calls this time but in terms
of the likelihood or that we're going to
see this happen I don't know I think to
it with the Dolphins situation makes it
interesting because we've heard so much
about Herbert you know being the guy
there with the dolphins and whether
people think that's a smoke screen or
not I tend to think it's actually pretty
legitimate so if you're the Chargers and
say you're a to a team right you really
want to it have just energized this this
city in this fan base and you've got a
really talented team and he can be the
face to replace Phillip Rivers do you do
you trust your gut and say man I think
they're gonna go Herbert so let's not
trade any assets let's sit here and wait
and we're going to get hurt we're gonna
get to us without having to give up any
pics or like you said I think use the
term right it's they get a itchy trigger
finger and and maybe they want to go up
that's a that's the storyline to follow
on the draft that's the number one story
in my opinion so when the Lions are on
the clock that 10 minute period that's
when we're that's when we start sitting
up a little bit more upright in our
chairs keeping an ear to the ground and
if the lines don't don't don't move it
is a Kudo but that's that's a that's a
that's the choice of Honolulu they they
go to the Ohio State and get at that
corner that to me is the one that makes
the most sense I just think he's a great
fit there that's the you know Patricia
way if you go off the Belichick playbook
which is where he came from and they
build their defense back to fronts that
are front to back so you lose Darius
slay you slide him in there I know some
people have said well why would you why
would you do that it's just kind of an
even swap if you could have kept slain
and it's gone in a different direction
but this is a younger cheaper version so
that still to me looks like the pic and
then a fourth overall Dave gentlemen
sitting in his attic in front of his one
single laptop know if you saw that
photograph that I think so again I'm I'm
not that's more Suzy my wife's area of
expertise I have heard you use the word
sconce a lot in our marriage GTV if the
Giants draft a kid named wainscotting
then you'll know real quick yes Rob
Brockman just mentioned HGTV how bad do
you feel I feel so bad for all those
people that went with the tiny houses
you know I don't know if that's such a
good call right now I'll say the same
thing to you Daniel that I've told may
out for many many a moon not
everything's an evaluation not
everything needs to be evaluated but
that is you're you're in that mode right
now you only know one speed right yeah
everything's an evaluation they see even
even notice the wainscot
it goes around the corner so his
decision at four is huge right with
Simmons or the offensive lineman of his
choice or even trading out potentially
what do you think gentleman does when
it's all said and done fourth overall
well I just think he's a meat and
potatoes guy and it's a meat and
potatoes decision so you get the
offensive lineman to help Daniel Jones
and helps a qualm Barkley their defense
is terrible rich they have to use
resources to get that fixed but I don't
think that's number one on the
priorities I think next year if the
Giants are eight and eight and daniel
Jones is taking a step forward and
you've kept him healthy you feel like
you're on your way
you know to being a good football team
and you can fix some of those defensive
issues if they go eight and eight and
the defense plays great and keeps them
in every game and daniel Jones regresses
I don't think you feel good about where
that franchise is so I'm gonna fix that
offensive line so why do you think he
goes worse of all his choices at that
spot well we we still have another mock
to go here rich I've got a finale here
so I think I'm doing that with you I
think I think they're putting a camera
in my house today so I can do that with
you on Wednesday night on NFL Network Oh
Daniel
I think I think it'll be an offensive
tackle I'm beginning to think it's not
going to be worse but I do think they'll
go off into tackle there then why are
you why are you mock drafting worst is
you're giving a head fake just to keep
it fresh that's we've got a new one
coming your way hard names like what a
week is like a year and mocked around
what point our I don't even know what
point oh we're on right now so it's the
same it's the same I don't know who came
up with the point o for mock drafts I
don't know what they lineage of this
thing is but whoever it is it's the same
person that mandates every single
television partner of the National
Football League to write around week 11
week 12 name all the teams outside of
the playoff picture in
hunt I don't know who that it's always
gotta be in the hunt as you know well I
guess we should bring this up right here
because we have a new audience on NBCSN
here on the Rich Eisen show we call it
sniffing it it might not be nearly as
appropriate for a television audience uh
for for partners but at any rate your
whatever point oh you've got Herbert in
front of tool right now why do you have
that is that is that your evaluation or
what you think the Dolphins evaluation
is right now Daniel yeah my evaluation
is you take two uh you know and I know
I'm not a doctor
but look at that to me would be my
decision but when I hear that there's a
split in the room and I've heard that
for multiple people that if there if
there's not a unanimous opinion on those
guys I would think it would lend towards
the healthier player getting the nod so
that's kind of a combination of what
I've heard and then just common sense of
this one guy's healthy and one guy is
coming off a tough injury so that's why
I had them going with Herbert but I've
also heard as of the last few days
talking around to the folks around the
league rich who believe they might not
even take a quarterback
come on shock me come on well that's
what I said I said that doesn't make any
sense you traded a bunch of great
players so you could go out and replace
them with other you know great players
no you did all this so you could get the
quarterback like that to come out of
this whole rebuild without the
quarterback just wouldn't make any sense
to me unless unless the quarterback that
they have coveted all this time suffered
a hip injury that's got him scared I
mean that that would be that would be
the only reason why one would think that
you're hearing this stuff unless and
you've been in draft rooms in your
lifetime in your career how do you sense
what's be us and what isn't right now I
mean that there's a split in the room
that might be being told to enough
people that it gets into your ear gate
to use the Michael Irvin phrase so
everybody thinks that they're not taking
to a fifth overall and they don't have
to trade up to go get the guy that they
still do covet Daniel it's very real
it's very real and on that in that vein
rich this year I tweet about this last
night this is going to be the the
wildest draft in terms of what your
expectations will be and what actually
happens because I'll let people in on a
little bit of a secret here when you
when you go to these pro days
all the coaches and all the scouts are
there and while the guy at the top of
the decision-making chain is is usually
aware of keeping things a little bit
close to the best there are
conversations inside that building and
there are people that know and a lot of
times those are coaches or scallops and
when they get around their buddies
that's how the information gets out
that's how you find out the team X likes
player why it's not coming straight from
that building it's because a friend of a
coach there talked to him at a pro day
and he didn't keep it to himself so all
this information comes out of these pro
day conversations that take place and we
didn't have that this year so I can I'm
still having conversations with these
general managers but they these these
staffs haven't been interacting with one
another so I'll have a full I'm having
these calls every night rich where it's
well talked about a player and he'll go
got really targeting this guy you know
he's a I think this kid could be a great
fit for us in the third round and then
talk to another team ten minutes later
and say what do you think of this guy
like I'll he's a free agent for us like
he stinks there's like these wide swings
on these players there's no groupthink
this year every man for himself which
makes it a lot of fun that is remarkable
I have not heard that yet and that is a
fascinating development to hear so you
think again and I understand there's
another mock draft to come Herbert over
tulle and that would be champagne
popping for the Chargers right I mean
you call chargers games here in Los
Angeles on the radio along with our
buddy Matt money Smith that would be
telesco like if he could write it up
right now that's the way he would write
it up what'd you say
well to me assuming that he's healthy I
think he's just a such a perfect fit on
the field in the locker room in the city
like everything points to a very good
fit there with two oh but I'm not privy
to the medical information that they
have so that would determine that
decision but man you know looking at it
on paper rich it it looks to me like it
would be a home run pitch how about how
are these teams truly flying blind on
tour and his hip
Daniel though I mean like he got the
check at the combine and then there was
that medical me check that that checked
out apparently according to all reports
you
watching him run around spry like a deer
with all the video that from his his own
personal pro day that got sent to a lot
of people in our industry I mean Howard
people truly flying blind on to his
health
right now DJ well I think it's there's
two questions with to his health and
I've heard different opinions on this
from different medical people and some
teams are more comfortable with it than
others but then these are teams are not
in the quarterback markets there's no
reason for them to lie to me I know
they're not taking one I'm just looking
for their opinion I like it but but the
situation is this there's getting to a
100 percent healthy which if you watch
that video I mean I thought it was
incredible for where he is in the
process he looked like he was you know
85 90 percent I mean look great but
there's a difference between getting to
100% and staying at 100% and that's
where the issue lies for some teams it's
not is he going to be healthy when he
walks into our building for the first
time it's it's what's the likelihood of
recurrence with this injury and what
kind of stability are we going to have
going forward in the long term that's
the question so you're in a draft room
though you take to it right you do it I
would yeah yeah he's my look I still
have Borough is my top quarterback right
but you know he's in Cincinnati he's
gone I would take to her okay and
Simmons drops to 10 and you're in your
in your mock draft I mean what obviously
the Browns would be ecstatic to get
somebody as talented as Isaiah summons
but don't they they got to get somebody
up front right I mean so what do you
think of the brown scenario involving
Simmons and I guess everything that
we've just discussed all the way down to
10 there DJ yeah I think the Simmons
thing would be interesting because if
you look I had Jacksonville taking
beckon and there's a couple different
thoughts on that you know I would say
it's probably down the line chance that
the Jags would actually take back then
at that point time but that's a trade
spot when you look at Cleveland at 10 as
a tackle team the Jets at 11 or a tackle
team so if you wanted to tackle if
you're a team like Tampa we want to go
up there and get a tackle that's the
spot you want to get to is Jacksonville
and I've been told by multiple teams
that Jacksonville is more than willing
to get out and actually
could be looking to get out so that
could be a trade spot there and if that
happens now you have that run on tackles
and then Simmons being there I think
we'll just be too good of a too good of
a player there for Cleveland to pass up
when you're in that division with Lamar
Jackson and you have a player like Isiah
Simmons and I saw it with their when
James against the Baltimore Ravens
you know the playoffs a couple years ago
that that is kind of an eraser for a you
know the unique player like Lamar he
really gives you a lot of advantages
there on the defensive side of the ball
at all he can do so that's a pick for
the division there if they were to
somehow get Isaiah Simmons now I think
Simmons is the third best player in the
draft but he's an off the ball
linebacker moving to a lot of different
things but those guys you seen in years
past
or highly rated off the ball linebackers
can drop a little bit so I thought would
not totally shock me if Isaiah Simmons
did not go quite as high as he should
based on his ability and then last one
for you Daniel we had our buddy Charles
Davis on in our first hour our
youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show
streamed our and he said that the
signing of Mariota in Las Vegas makes
him think that Mayo car buddy and Gruden
are not going to go quarterback in the
first round where do you think Jordan
love winds up well first of all before I
get to that has Charles got the blazer
yet because I told them as soon as that
CBS blazer shows up he needs to snap a
picture and I did it tonight I think
it's at the Taylor right now I think
it's still being sewn together with tees
being crossed and I's being dotted and
by Taylor I mean his entertainment
lawyer that's what I mean that makes
sense
that makes sense
he's tough to nail down he's the one I'm
just having a hard time I don't think
the Raiders will take him maybe I'll be
surprised but I don't think they will
and then to me it it could work out
really well for Jordan love because if I
was him there'd be three teams that I
would want to go to everybody grows up
you want to be the number one pick
forget that this is a long game here you
want to go to a place where they can
develop you and you have a chance to be
successful and Jordan love those three
teams would be New Orleans at the bottom
of the first round it would also be
Indianapolis
essentially coming back up to pick him
in the bottom of the first round that
would be an option form as well
and I don't think New England would do
it but he would have an opportunity to
sit there as well I don't think that
they will take him but the two that make
the most sense are the Saints and the
Colts and you have however in your
current Mach a team at watched attackers
you have a team that watched a talented
quarterback drop and they've been riding
him and he'll be riding all the way to
the Hall of Fame since then you have the
Packers taking Jordan love 30th overall
that would be that that would be the
third team that would be the third team
so you've got again great situations
with offensive minded coaches and then
you've got a chance to sit and learn and
develop what she needs so you know the
Packers tried that with the Shawn Kaiser
it didn't work out
maybe they go back to that well again
here with it with a new group running
the show and and jordan loves got a
tremendous amount of talent so it'd be
fun
DJ fun chatting with you look forward to
chatting with you more next week thanks
Daniel
all right you got it that YouTube Daniel
Jeremiah hat move the sticks must follow
love that guy hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here